hi there everyone and welcome back to
the channel this video is going to be a
deep dive into tuning your am32 ESC so
we're going to be looking at how to
maximize the performance of the ESC to
enable your motor to accelerate and
decelerate as fast as possible giving
you the best flight performance keeping
your quad as stable as possible in the
air for super smooth footage and we're
also going to be looking at how to
minimize the risk that the ESC loses
track of the motor as it's spinning and
you get a desync and the quad falls out
of the sky so we're also going to be
talking about that it's a lot to cover
in one video I'm not going to waste any
more time let's dive right into it if
you're looking to get the best possible
experience out of your drone then I have
to let you know about my configuration
and tuning guides they're available over
on my patreon I've got PDF guides for
betaflight 4.5 BL heli 32 and now am32
they're really detailed and they take
you step by step through every setting
and how to tune it to get your drone
flying as good as it possibly can and
because they're PDF guides they're easy
for a quick reference you can take them
with you on your phone in the field and
also I keep them more up to date than
the videos because it's is much easier
to update them so if you're looking for
the latest and greatest information all
backed up by my scientific testing then
please check out the links in the video
description and head on over to my
patreon and I really appreciate any
support that you can give before we go
through the results I just want to give
you a quick overview of the equipment
that I use to collect all this test data
starting with the motors and props so
for the 3-in testing we using this Zing
2404 3800 KV driving a 3in hqt 3x3x3
prop for the 5-in testing we're using
this AOS Supernova 2207 1980 KV this is
the most powerful and fastest
accelerating 6s 5in motor that I've ever
tested so it's going to really put this
ESC through its paces and it's driving
the HQ 5x 4.5 by3 v1s prop which is my
standard test prop for 5-in motors for
the in motor we have the AOS Supernova
2807 14400 KV this is the best
performing 7-in motor in its weight
category and again it's really able to
put the ESC through its Paces with a lot
of power and torque and it's driving
this HQ 7x 3.5 by3 v1s test prop the ESC
that I'm going to be using is the Sky
Stars km55 amp it's running am32 version
2.12 and it's you can see this is the
here I've just got a spare that's going
to be connected to this F7 flight
controller which is going to be doing
the logging over bidirectional dshot for
all of the acceleration and deceleration
tests all of the efficiency and thrust
tests you're going to see are going to
be logged by this Tito robotics 1585
thrust test stand to make sure that all
the tests are fair and consistent we're
going to be powering these motors from a
big battery the 7in and 5-in motors are
going to be powered from a 52 200 Mah 6s
pack kept topped up to 24 volts by a
power supply and the 3-in class motor is
going to be run off this 5200 Mah 4S
pack kept topped up to 16 volts by the
power supply and that just makes sure
that all of the accelerations that we're
going to be doing are absolutely
consistent using this test setup I did
two different types of test the first
test was a throttle ramp from 0 to 100%
throttle over 10 seconds and during that
ramp I'm looking at things like the
shape of the thrust curve the efficiency
of the motor ESC and prop combination so
the whole powertrain and I'm also
looking at the maximum thrust and power
that the motor is able to produce the
second test is a throttle step where I'm
stepping the motor between 10 and 50%
throttle and back again and in that test
I'm looking at how fast the ESC can
accelerate and decelerate the motor from
that 10 to 50% throttle setting and
that's really important for keeping the
quad nice and stable in the air so those
are the two types of tests that we're
going to be looking at in these results
we're going to start by looking at the
3-in 3,800 KV motor and we're going to
start by looking at timing timing is a
really interesting setting because what
it controls is when the ESC fires the
coil relative to when the magnet passes
opposite the end of the coil if we have
a timing of 0° that means that the coil
is fired exactly when the magnet is
directly opposite the end of the coil if
we have some positive timing some timing
Advance as it's called that means that
we're firing the coil slightly before
the magnet passes directly opposite the
end of the coil and the reason we want
some timing Advance is because it takes
a little bit of time for the field to
build up in the coil to reach a a a
strength because the coil has some
inductance and the more inductance the
coil has the longer it's going to take
for that field to build up when we have
a very low timing we tend to get better
performance but at the risk of desyncs
because if we're not firing the coil
till the magnet is directly opposite it
um then sometimes we can lose control of
the rotor and that can cause a desync
however if we're firing the coil well
before the magnet has passed the end of
the coil then what that means is that
for some time we're actually pushing
against the motor so we're actually
slowing the motor down initially before
the magnet passes the end of the coil
and then we're pushing to accelerate the
motor so firing the coil to early
reduces Motor Performance and also
potentially can reduce a little bit of
motor efficiency as well what we see
with our 3-in motor is that a slightly
faster response is achieved with lower
timing on am32 so we have motor RPM on
the y-axis and time in milliseconds on
the x-axis so the motor that accelerates
the most quickly or the setting that
accelerates the most quickly is giving
us the best response and we can see that
we get an improvement in resp response
when we move from 22 1/2 to 15° of
timing a another slightly smaller
Improvement when we move from 15 to 7
1/2 and then a very small negligible
Improvement when we move from 7 and 1/2
to 0° of timing it's a similar story
with deceleration again we've got motor
RPM on the y- AIS and time on the x-axis
we can see that we get a small
Improvement in deceleration
responsiveness when we move from 22 1/2
to 15° of timing but then almost no
improvement decreasing timing below 15°
we get maybe a very small amount of
improvement to 7 1/2 and then absolutely
no improvement from 7 1/2 to 0° of
timing looking now at the relationship
between thrust and timing we can see
that the throttle curve is slightly
different for different timings we've
got thrust here on the y-axis versus
throttle percent on the x-axis and that
the higher timings have a slightly
higher throttle curve than the lower
timings but then everything sort of
evens out by the time you get up to Full
Throttle I don't think this would be
noticeable on the sticks but we can
detect something on the thrust test
stand looking at efficiency versus
timing now we've still got thrust on the
y- AIS but now we have electrical power
on the x-axis and what we can see is
that at high throttles it does look like
efficiency might be very slightly better
at 7 and 1 half degrees of timing but
the difference is very marginal and it
disappears at lower throttle settings
where you're more likely to be cruising
so I don't think we can make a firm
recommend recommendation on timing based
on efficiency all the timing settings
perform very very similarly in terms of
efficiency so my 3-in timing
recommendation is going to be as a safe
setting 15° that's going to give you
good performance and it's going to be
very resilient against desyncs and I
would recommend that for any 3-in quad
if you're a racing pilot and you're
looking for the maximum possible
performance then you could consider
ticking it down one more Notch and going
to
72° and that is going to give you a a
little bit more performance but you will
need to test it out to make sure that
you're not getting desyncs but if you
don't get desyncs at 72° then you are
going to be getting better performance
now let's talk about pwm frequency this
is how fast the fets are switched on and
off to control the throttle setting of
the motor if you're at Full Throttle
100% then the fets won't be switching at
all so pwm frequency doesn't matter in
that case but when you're at less than
Full Throttle the battery voltage is
Switched on and off the fets very very
fast to give you a throttle value less
than 100% And the frequency of this
switching is the pwm frequency and it
has some quite interesting effects on
Motor Performance as we're going to see
let's start by looking at motor
acceleration versus pwm frequency and
what we have is we have motor RPM on the
y-axis versus time on the x-axis and you
can see that all of our pwm frequencies
here are ranges and that's because am32
has variable pwm by default what that
means is that the frequency of the pwm
changes with the motor RPM and the
reason they do this is to keep the pwm
frequency away from the commutation
frequency which is to do with the
rotation frequency of the motor if you
have pwm frequency matching up with
commutation frequency you can get notchy
throttle where the uh motor will want to
stay at a certain throttle position or
it'll want to stay at a certain RPM at a
certain throttle and that gives a notchy
throttle feel and sometimes that's not
desirable moving the pwm frequency so
that they never line up keeps the
throttle response really nice and smooth
so we always have a range and the top
number the highest pwm that the motor is
ever going to go to is always twice the
lower number so we got 16 to 32 24 to 48
36 to 72 48 to 96 what we can see is
that increasing from 16 to 24 khz pwm
has an improvement in terms of the
acceleration of the motor and then we
see another Improvement moving from 24
to 36 and then a much smaller
Improvement moving from 36 to 48k so you
can see we get diminishing returns as we
continue to increase pwm frequency if we
look now at the deceleration of the
motor we see the precise opposite of
that so we see an improvement in the
deceleration of the motor when we
decrease the pwm frequency so we're
going from 48 to 36 we get an
improvement and then we get a very small
improvement from 36 to 24 and another
very small improvement from 24 to 16 so
again diminishing returns once we get
below about 36k at the low end uh we
don't see much improvement beyond that
looking at thrust versus pwm the thrust
curves are nearly identical regardless
of the pwm frequency so we're not going
to be making a decision based on that
and the efficiency curves are also
nearly identical versus pwm frequency
apart from maybe very low pwm
frequencies like 16 to 32k at low
throttle they are definitely less
efficient but we weren't going to pick
those super low pedium frequencies
anyway because the acceleration is quite
slow this gives us a very clear
recommendation for 3-in Motors in terms
of pwm frequency I would say 36 to 72
khz gives the best balance of
acceleration and deceleration the best
efficiency so that's going to be the one
that you're going to want to pick for
that smaller 3-in size motor the final
setting we're going to look at is called
motor C V and what this setting actually
does is it controls the amount of
throttle the ESC will apply to the motor
at low RPMs the lower the KV setting the
more throttle uh the am32 ESC will apply
to the motor at low RPMs to cause it to
accelerate and so this setting is
somewhat similar to ramp up power in BL
heli 32 apart from a lower motor KV
setting corresponds to a higher ramp up
power so so this is something that you
need to look at and tune quite carefully
because just reducing the motor KV and
dumping more current into the motor to
try and get it to accelerate faster
works up to a point but at some point
you saturate the motor and then all that
extra current just goes into heat and
that can cause the motor to get very hot
and you don't get any more performance
you just lose efficiency so now let's
take a look at motor KV looking at
acceleration versus motor KV we can see
we've got motor RPM on the y AIS versus
time on the x-axis and if you set the
motor KV setting really high to like
10,000 KV for 3,800 KV motor you can see
that the motor accelerates very slowly
and actually it doesn't even reach its
full RPM value so it doesn't even get up
to the 19,000 RPM which it should reach
it only gets to about 15
16,000 if you then decrease a setting to
8,000 6,000 4,000 so you're bringing the
motor KV setting down towards the True
Value the acceleration improves
massively and that's because the ESC is
able to apply more throttle at those
lower RPMs and accelerate the motor more
quickly however you don't see much
benefit decreasing the motor KV setting
below the true value of the motor KV you
can see that going from 4,000 to 3,000
gives us very very little benefit if any
at all and Below 3,000 there is no
benefit to decreasing the motor KV
further so there's no point pushing the
motor KV down below below the true value
of the motor KV because you're just
going to dump more current into the
motor when it's already saturated it's
not going to accelerate any faster and
all that extra current is just going to
be wasted as heat so you don't want to
do that but also you do want to make
sure that the motor KV value is
correctly set in the am32 firmware so
that you're getting the best
acceleration and you're avoiding heating
up the motor too much looking at
deceleration we can see that motor KV
has no effect on motor deceleration at
all
if you set the KV setting way way too
high uh the motor won't accelerate up to
the correct RPM because it won't get
enough throttle and that obviously
affects the deceleration curve as well
but you can ignore that all of the other
settings have exactly the same
deceleration curve they sit on top of
each other there's no difference so that
setting just doesn't matter for
deceleration that makes the 3-in motor
KV recommendation really really simple
just set it correctly according to the
stated motor KV and if you can't set the
number exactly because you've not got a
setting for exactly 3,800 always ER on
the lower side so pick
3780 rather than
3,820 that'll make sure that you're
always slightly below the stated motor
KV rather than slightly above and that's
going to make sure that you're always
getting the best possible performance
now that we've gone through the results
for the 3-in motor in detail I'm going
to give you the results and my
recommendations for the 5 in and 7in
Motors by similarity so we're not going
to go through every chart I'm going to
pick out the ones that are different and
then I'm going to give you my
recommendations just to be respectful of
your time if you would like to look at
all of the detailed charts for every
test every setting on the 5 and 7in
Motors as well then that's all available
in the PDF tuning guide on my patreon
and I'd really appreciate it if you'd
sign up and go and check that out and
that will give you all the raw raw data
that underlies these recommendations
first of all I just wanted to show you
what a desync looks like in my test data
so here we're looking at the 5-in
acceleration test with different timings
and on the Zer degree timing setting we
consistently got a desync with the rapid
acceleration test so you can see that
the acceleration performance improves
reducing from 22 1/2 to 15° of timing 7
1/2 much the same and then 0 degrees you
get this very clear desync where uh the
ESC is no longer able to accelerate the
motor and it just loses control so this
is the risk with running zero degrees of
timing and that's why I would never
recommend that anyone run timings that
low um here we see that there's actually
no benefit to decreasing timing Beyond
15° the other graph that I wanted to
show you is the really extreme effect
that having a motor KV setting that's
way too high for the motor can have so
here we've got the 7in motor 1,400 KV
nominal and we have a setting of 10,000
and 8,000 KV that just just can't even
accelerate the motor at all it only gets
it up to about 6,000 RPM as we decrease
the motor KV setting performance
improves and we get accelerations that
get up closer to the correct value which
is about 14,000 RPM once we're down at
4,000 KV so twice uh three times the
state value then we're getting something
that's
reasonable and as we decrease further
2,500 KV again we see the acceleration
um stop improving so that's when we're
reaching the correct level of
acceleration the maximum acceleration
that the motor is capable of this is
really important particularly if you're
running larger 8 or 10in quads and you
have very low motor KVs 900 KV 800 KV
maybe even 400 KV you need to go into
the am32 settings and you need to adjust
your motor KV correctly for that motor
otherwise it may not accelerate properly
or it may not accelerate as fast as it's
able
to the defa setting I think is around
2,000 KV on am32 so that's going to work
if you're running a 5 in or a 6 in or a
7in quad and it's fine although you
probably should increase it for smaller
quads like 3 in but if you're running an
8 or 10in quad that's got less than
1,000 KV Motors you're definitely going
to need to go into that setting and
adjust it down to make sure that the
acceleration is going to be correct with
those differences called out let's dive
into the recommendations starting with
timing and the recommendations for
timing are the same as for 3-in Motors
so 15° I recommend as safe for all quads
and it's going to give you slightly
better performance in general than
222° if you want to try and push for
even more performance then you might get
a little bit more benefit out of 7.5 de
but it is going to increase the risk of
desyncs and I would never ever use Zer
degree timing with these larger Motors
because the risk of desyncs is just way
too high so 15° is safe 72° you can try
um but does increase the risk of detin a
bit don't use zero for my pwm
recommendation I would say that for
these larger Motors 24 to 48 khz gave
the best balance of acceleration and
deceleration in my testing and the
graphs look almost identical to the 3-in
plots but there's just a slightly
different tradeoff between the different
frequencies for these larger Motors that
gives 24 to 48k a little bit of an
advantage so that's the one that I would
re recommend and um definitely use the
variable pwm just to avoid any risk of
that notchy throttle in terms of motor
KV settings is exactly the same
recommendation as for the 3-in motor
which is to set it correctly according
to the stated motor KV and to always on
slightly lower so if you can't match the
value exactly just take the setting one
tick lower rather than one tick higher
and that will just guarantee that you're
always getting the best performance
hopefully these settings are going to
help you get the maximum possible
performance out of your am32 ESC I am
going to be doing some further testing
with smaller Motors so we're going to be
looking at some tiny motors with
esc's running blue jay firmware so make
sure you like subscribe hit the bell all
of that good stuff so that you can see
that tuning video as soon as it comes
out and of course I'm going to be
creating a whole tuning guide for blue
jay firmware along with that as well
focusing on Tiny whoops that's all I
have for you for today so until next
time I wish you all very very happy
flying
[Music]